welcome to this video playing
international master Michele Michele
from Finland I'm playing a weird line
the coop right shake variation early
Bishop d7 one of the better of beat
Sicilians this is one point you
sometimes get the bishop to c6 yeah
that's that's very interesting the worst
thing is that i have forgotten how you
play that really ok i probably need to
do i need to do this ok i am not sure
I'm not sure if I need to but I'll do it
anyway so probably now going to see 5 I
need to get rid of this Queen on h5 it's
just just too annoying oh that's
surprising at least it's surprising for
me and not and playing this opening for
the first time I only recently saw game
with it and thought okay this is
interesting but I think normally in this
kind of structures it is considered that
to BM to be good for blood to have the
Queen's exchanged and he just allowed
that without any in particular yeah I
without yeah I don't see any great
benefit for him in doing that
okay it's important that on f5 I have
keen 7 now I guess I don't want to play
a five and now the King only seven
defends d6 together with the rook e6 is
also defended and my absolute dream
would be to interesting move would be to
get the bishop to e5 see going for
before and maybe but okay this is good
anyway intending Bishop f4 to e5 and if
I manage that it's excellent I think he
must play g3 a.m. and he did now I can
actually get the bishop over maybe you
know I briefly thought he can play
rookie one night if I had something okay
takes pawn tags okay pawn takes he's got
this look check yeah okay nice move 95
okay this means I I need to be content
with this check which is obviously not
not too brilliant yeah so it still is it
still should be ok but i really thought
i was i was in good shape before and
this now can be at best yeah fighting
fighting for draw upon down
okay yeah you've got this weakness here
I need to get this a tactical claim the
show p.m. Wow
do I need to play Bishop b6 really it's
not not great yeah but I don't see what
else really this Roxy said namine Bishop
b6 and Roxy 7 was really a really a
problem when tending Bishop c5 try to
block the queenside maybe I could have
played it immediately
not what i wanted to do really not okay
here
count the h-bond it's just the edge
ponent and don't I don't have any
particular counter play wow this 95
minutes was really a really a big
problem time warning Jim yeah you just
promotes this bloody h-bond black resign
yeah this was a bad game by me yeah
really this must be this must battle for
black really there's no way that's not
good for black I've got two bishops and
the structures is this is really good I
only need to avoid any technical tricks
I don't think this can be anything great
for white 95 was great though so this is
just not good because of 95 m amazing
really amazing remarkable what what what
what I need to do here I mean what what
would be excellent is to get one pair of
roofs off or even two pairs imagine this
position with rooks exchanged black is
flat-out winning because my bishop pair
will put so much pressure on the pawns
that he cannot defend it so I need to
get the rooks exchanged of course what I
wanted to do is I wanted to activate the
bishop oops here first but that it got
hit by this great 95 move really great
so this is not good I need to do
something else and
my suggestion is to go here then here
and maybe rook the bishop back to get
one look out of the out of blacks camp
and maybe try to exchange rooks this
would be a would be excellent something
like that yeah this is the cult
attending and it gives this as a
possible drawing line yeah maybe maybe
white has enough activity with this 95
tricks to to damage services I didn't
paint that don't know how it came up
well I don't know this this looks I mean
I know positions like that like that
they often pop up in the Rosa variation
and with Queens on they are normally
good for white with Queens off black is
in excellent shape and I have got Queen
Sofia maybe yeah maybe it is some it is
just about okay for white possible if I
don't get the rooks exchanged and all my
bishop activated then then I'm willing
to believe that yeah but this was very
strong this 95 muchas very strong and
this this is even really awful so I need
to do that and come here jani gym he's
just winning the spawn gym I thought I
have enough count to play against
against against these pawns but it
didn't materialize I mean I lost a lost
a couple of the moves and such
a turn chair remarkable yeah it's
probably just just bad yeah I'm
wondering about the defense IAM if there
is some some tougher defense of a
available with opposite colored bishops
i mean there should be some way to at
least a fight but it's possible that
it's just just not it's not sufficient
and after this h4 he would always play
at a later stage after preparation g4
and get the h-bond maybe this is really
too bad possible yeah i played a good
game there he really played a good game
g3 / should be 3m yeah yeah i need to
Danny to get i need to do this
regrouping he tells to me heh watch on
schlechte neither that's nonsense Black
is at least equal him that's absolutely
this is nonsense blankets never worse
absolutely never because he can do
nothing I can just sit through and wait
and nothing happens yeah but it's um
it's um it's it's tricky alright thanks
for watching